no
you are inviting these things into your
home on a deeper level
she was listening to music at the time
so you want to be so as a result it made
it easy for me to possess a different
section murdering ludicrous
uh jay-z all this stress all i got is
this big house coming from a musician's
background i can totally relate to that
he began the gin began to speak to the
brother um and actually having
intercourse with them and they can't see
it
okay now the information you're brought
to me now my opinion is a bit different
now i see where you're coming from
perhaps some of the some of the
quote-unquote scholars
bismillah
subscribe if you haven't already and my
next guest is no stranger to the dean
show we've had him on before
former deaf jam
musical artist and i'm excited to have
him on the program a lot to talk about a
lot to talk about he was with the likes
of russell simmons l cool j you know
people who are on this record label and
now he's on the dean's show
and
let's bring him on salaam brother how
are you
how you doing brother alhamdulillah
give us a little how you been
excellent man it's good to see you again
it's been a long time man
it's really good to see you how's
everything uh in your part of the world
you're in gambia now
alhamdulillah yes i'm here in gambia and
uh the blessed land of the muslims
it's uh it's a beautiful place to be
done
so thank allah
give give us a little bit of run down so
umar aka
uh the dubose
did i say it right
yes
the voice
dubois
dubois former jeff definitely sounds
cooler than ever
def jam artist you know people ask me
why do you like talking about this
industry talking to people with yourself
and loon and people like napoleon these
people who've been in
that industry because i would say what
would you say the percentage
are of muslims non-muslims people who
are following the path you know
listening to the music
of the people in the industry what would
you say if you had to guess the
percentage-wise 90 percent 95
muslims yeah the people in general or
muslims let's say
i would say the percentage of people
that listen to music is probably i mean
it's 99.9
of the world you know 99. so these
people in in that industry in the music
industry like def jam and what are the
other you know where it be rock and roll
hip hop uh yes
i mean i would say the the if you
if you want to split it up
it's as if subanalyze if today
the the uh the hip-hop industry has
become the way the rock industry was
before
it's just as popular now i mean you have
people out there that are
just as popular as as rock artists i
mean this is crazy
give us a little bit give us a little
bit of about a rundown a little bit like
uh sort of people who didn't get to see
your story before give us a little bit
of a rundown of uh what your um past as
far as the record label and who you were
associated with
back then
so just to give people a background for
those who have not uh you know seen any
video footage or anything uh regarding
our video videos before
um
my past
uh former island def jam artist
uh was signed to uh i was actually leo
cohen and tina davis were the ones that
signed me at that time
um
and
during that time
um
you know you have artists such as music
soul child there's so many things on the
same label with me
um
geru from new york
was actually uh people like jairu they
were actually in a different section
murder inc ludicrous
um jay-z all this stress all i got is
this big house was on uh def jam at that
time i'm not sure if he still is or not
but you know they were on their their
side rockefeller you know even walking
walking in the office
you would you would see at the time uh
you would be able to see
who's selling the most et cetera you
will be able to see these things in the
hallway when you walk through them um
this is an example of some of the people
that were on the label uh at the same
time as myself
have you ever heard of this uh
individual here i'm gonna go ahead and
play a little clip
and let me know if you these are some of
these new names that have come up and i
did a segment i was talking about this
and i'll tell you the reason why after
we watched this
okay dolph determined when doc won
dropped dolphins spent all the money on
doc i can't think of one person and gave
me a dollar a coin
it's bigger than life you know what i'm
saying
but
if you think i'm finna go out like
parking bigger you must be stupid
you know what i'm saying like it's 2017.
this is the danger are you familiar with
young dolph
young dolph
eddie so many of these new artists i'm
not even familiar with him
i was the same way but he mentioned some
he mentioned he mentioned someone in
there he mentioned uh biggie
so you wanna be hardcore with your hat
to the back biggie and
tupac right okay
you you knew that you are you familiar
with them
you were you know what captain what was
interesting about this story
was that he was talking about uh dolph
young dolph they called him a very
famous rapper i have never heard of him
before
but the interesting what caught our
attention because a lot of the news was
reporting on his death
he actually just died so this clip in
the beginning is talking about you know
how you see the beginning he's going to
determine when he's going to drop and he
wasn't going to follow or it wasn't
going to happen to him what happened to
biggie and smalls then he got in some
beef with some other uh yo gotti and
these guys when you're researching you
see like the you know the beef that was
going on so kind of the similar just
history repeating itself
right and then you go there's like
thousands of ways you know and more you
can die but he ended up going to a
cookie shop and that was it he got
gunned down he got gunned down you can
watch this video that i did on it so
what do you think you know when you when
you see that like you know you got in
there
uh these are the new rappers that are
coming up and you know a lot of the
youth imitating and following these
people and taking them as role models
i mean when you when you see situations
like this i mean um like you said it's
history repeating itself it's history
repeating itself and and it's it's this
as a result of the environment
that environment that they're placing
themselves in
um where there's a competition
that is of no benefits in the hereafter
it's a competition
that you know that has absolutely no
benefit in the hereafter at all
you know when you see that um
i don't know i mean it's it's like you
said it's something that it's a cycle
because it's happened so many times
since the situation with um tupac and
vicki
we've seen a number of cases like this
where you may you may not even hit the
news but
certain things that take place it may
not even hit the news but we hear about
it behind the scenes
whether it's the club fights whether
somebody is fighting in the strip club
wherever it may be
those places where where where evil
normally takes place
um
yes i mean you find these type of things
happen and it's all the environments
we can't express how how much the
environment is actually responsible for
these things the production of that
environment and music is one of those
things that helps produce those
environments as we spoke about
previously in one of our previous
episodes
about how the
the the place music has a place of
worship
just like you know uh
people have churches people have
messages for places of worship people
have synagogues for places for worship
etc
you know likewise the the music
the music uh
music has a place of worship
it has a place of worship and that's the
nightclub
that's the strip club
you know how places of worship where
certain things take place
and it's in regards to the churches uh
in regards to you know the music that
takes place here i think is a that's a
whole different
discussion in itself because people many
people perceive that or perceive that
there's a such thing as good music
you understand
people have a perception i was actually
speaking to someone regarding this last
night he was basically saying that you
know he was he was
he was wondering how can
something be evil
if
in his essence
he felt he felt like music was created
by god in other words you understand so
how can something like music be evil
this was his whole argument and i simply
asked him
i said
i want you to think about this for a
second
now
who constructed a guitar who put it
together who manufactured it
and who taught people how to manufacture
something in order for sound to come out
i said do you think it was god
such a guitar
a piano it had to be manufactured
now we're referring to the human voice
that's something different this is
something that clearly allah has created
the human voice
so that's something that's a whole
different story
that's a whole different subject there
but when you're talking about something
that has been manufactured such as a
flute a saxophone uh harmonica
drums whatever you want to call it it's
been manufactured and someone has taught
people how to manufacture that who is
that somebody
this is the conversation that happened
what was the end of that
what how uh how did that conversation go
at the end when you talk because it's
different like you know the average lame
person talking about it but you were at
one point your whole life was revolving
around this industry wanting to be a
part of it and then you became a part of
it and then now you're around these you
know you know super you know these uh
musicians and these stars right so you
know the ins and outs
exactly and this is what i was trying to
explain to him you know you know this is
why i lost allah mentions
ask the people of knowledge if you don't
if you don't know
and this is the way this is explained by
scholars is that if a person is a doctor
or if you want to know about medicine
you go absolute you go back to the
doctor
if you want to know about law you go ask
the lawyer
if you want to know how to play if you
want to know how to play basketball you
don't ask tiger woods you don't ask
tiger boys you go to michael jordan
you understand
so likewise someone
if they want to know about music eddie
go ask those people that were involved
in it
go ask if you want to know about hip-hop
go ask somebody like napoleon
or go ask somebody like amir brother
you're formerly known as loom go ask
these people about hip-hop
even myself you can ask me about that
environment because i was in all of
those environments so you have to ask
the people that know
and they will be able to explain to you
as we mentioned before
you know the whole concept of musical
genius and these things where did this
come from what does it mean
it's beautified but what does it mean
you understand on a deeper level what
does it really mean
and people need to understand that
because you can look in the you can look
in the webster dictionary the word
genius comes from the word ginny
and people don't understand this when
you understand what these people use the
type of words they use
and uh you start to understand
uh on a deeper level deeper level what
these things mean then
you understand who is the manufacturer
of those instruments
there's no one else but he believes
himself
shaytan himself has taught people how to
create these instruments
how to how to uh move and dance these
things are whispered to people
you know on a deeper level this is how
we understand
i like what you said it's crazy yeah
i like what you say yeah it's very deep
i like what you said you compared many
of these places
to uh houses of worship for shaitaan
yes
that's steve absolutely so yeah that's
so nice so so next time if somebody
visits one of those i mean we're saying
it's from a place of love i mean many
people that we know we you know have
have
you know it's like somebody who's gone
down that path and you don't want
someone to go down that road of
destruction so we're warning the people
you know trying to uh you know
absolutely give them some of this
some of this uh warning before you go
down and then you end up destroying the
heart you know which is absolutely
amazing absolutely
i mean we we have to advise the people
the best of the best of our ability
everyone has their own decision to make
and i'm the love one thing i like to
always express to people that look we
are all under construction
we are all under construction until you
go to the grave none of us are perfect
but we're striving to get better as
human beings every single day every
single day i only can tell you from my
own experience what i know and
understand
because
people must understand i was able to
play multiple instruments so i can walk
into my own studio
in a few hours and come out with a song
i was one of those types of people
you know and everybody knew me for that
so the thing is that
who better to tell you
about what's going on regarding
instruments than someone who used to
actually
eddie i should play guitar for eight
hours a day
eight hours
eight hours a day playing the guitar wow
eight hours a day i should play guitar
and more hours of spit playing piano
you understand
so
my day was filled up with music
i didn't know anything else
you understand
um
i took time out to read books here and
there
and this is one of the things
alhamdulillah that led me to islam but
i'm just trying to give people a picture
an idea
to help them understand where i come
from
you know this this this area you know it
it it's something i can speak about for
many hours
you know and only islam
only islam that he gave me that
gave me that true satisfaction yeah
because as i mentioned before
we know that
music is something
that was set up in order to mimic what
allah's penal dollar does
you understand
it's something that
if you look at the quran
and you look at music
you can read it
you can listen to it and you can write
it down and you can memorize it
all four things
all four things
you can do them both with the quran
and music
do people think this is an accident
when the speech of allah is challenged
by something such as music but they have
the opposite effect
one destroys the heart
and one brings life to the heart
you understand
one one one gives life to the heart as
the loss of penalty mentions in the
quran
that the quran is what gives life is
something that gives life to the heart
give give gave life to even souls that
were once dead whereas music it will
tease your ears for a second you will
feel good
and then you will be depressed again
and you will go for that you will go for
that same cycle over and over and over
again
i always tell people just pay attention
one one indication that we see
or sign that allah is clearly left for
people
for people that that think and reflect
is the you know is how people die
you know it's important for people to
pay attention to how people die
where they how do they die you know if
you look at
spanish and they look how jimmy hendrix
died for example as an example and this
is someone that
i you know quote unquote idolized back
in the day
you know
i had pictures of jimmy jimi hendrix
everywhere on my wall
and he died
you know um
in a very horrible statement
died in a bad state
asphyxiation or something they call it
where a person is like you know
i believe that is when a person is is um
like dying on his own vomit you know or
something similar to that i don't know
it was serious
how about elvis presley how about
alcohol etc you know how about elvis
presley
you heard how he died right also similar
right
similar in many of these singers and
musicians they die in some very horrible
ways man
you know and you look at the opposite
or people that are reciters of the quran
you look at them you see that they if
you research
you will find that they died in more
peaceful states
you know
so it's a difference
it's the complete opposite
it's the complete opposite
and now when you mention it's
interesting usually we give these
examples like madonna or elvis presley
for a certain generation and you would
think everybody would continue to you
know know them after some time but now
you say elvis presley like the new
generation coming up like who elvis who
was
yes so what are you leaving behind
that's very important what kind of
legacy and look at look at the people's
death it's amazing you actually spoke
about this
and then uh when we did our program
before
and it looks like
the brothers took a video
and put it together here
the brothers put a nice video together
from our show
let's see what you were talking about
before
[Music]
people don't understand like i mentioned
when you arouse yourself
with these things you're opening
yourself up to a whole nother world that
people don't understand and as you
mentioned the people the musicians
playing with the ouija board people
don't know what these people are doing
behind the scenes there's a reason these
these uh these women and these people
are screaming in the crowd for them
they're utilizing many people this is
you narrating right
yeah
and their performances and everything
people don't realize these things this
is a whole nother reality especially
many of the muslims are very ignorant
towards this fact they don't understand
that this is a whole other element it's
just not something that's you know
friendly and things like this no
you are inviting these things into your
home on a deeper level
some scholars refer to music
yeah so you remember that when you you
were going deep into this
and again this is ladies and gentlemen
this is coming for someone who is uh
in the music industry
uh with the record label def jam playing
the guitar and many other multiple
instruments eight hours a day knowing
the ins and outs so we're getting kind
of we're getting things exposed to us
and at a deeper level do you think
somebody can get will they take their
selves their dean to the next level
because what if somebody's like look you
know i'm uh reading quran you know or
someone can say things but only allah
knows what's going on at a deeper level
in their life but someone you hear this
like okay look i'm still practicing i
pray i'll read some quran i'll uh you
know do my uh other obligations but
what's wrong if i pick up the saxophone
guitar
and i get down with some jimi hendrix
still you know what i mean
i mean even hearing hearing you say that
right
it almost gives me the chills
because i mean
embracing the slime when i embrace the
slime everything did trickle off
immediately it's something that takes
time
and definitely
i would say most definitely if a person
can leave off music
eddie
if a person you know
it's a step-by-step process
and we could talk about some things in
order you know some things that may help
to secure that you know that addiction
or help them because it's an illness and
people don't realize it's a type of
illness
it's an addiction
um
but
if a person can leave that off
most definitely they're going to enjoy a
different type of islam
within themselves they they it's
definitely inshallah it's definitely a
step
a step towards becoming a better
motivation
because it's something that
um say for example if a person doesn't
listen to music
when they hear the quran the quran is
going to affect their heart in a
different way
even if a person doesn't understand
arabic for example
you can have a person and this is
something i that i encourage many people
to do
if a person doesn't stand doesn't
understand the arabic language
simply go and find
find someone that you you you enjoy
listening to
and they have the subtitles now on many
of these videos
listen to them recites and pay attention
to the translation at the same time you
hear them reciting
and see the effect the quran will have
on your heart
even if you don't see any translation if
a person just simply simply puts the
quran on his ears
and listens to the quran
they will have a totally different
effect it will have a totally different
effect on on a heart that is that is
abstaining from music
that is abstaining from listening to
music versus a heart that listens to
music
you will see a totally different effect
because that two things those two things
can't live in the same heart
love for music
and a love for quran cannot exist in the
same heart
repeat that
love for music if a person loves to
listen to music they're engaging in it
they can't love to listen to quran at
the same time those two things cannot
exist in the same heart they're going to
fight with one another they're going to
be like this
one is going to try to push the other
out
this is generally how it works and this
is something
over
500 years plus
that quran
music is the quran of shaytan this is
something that he mentioned
and this is something that uh
people like myself
eddie i didn't even have you know was
was very interesting
this is before i even started seeing
text
related to music in islam i already felt
in my heart that music is evil something
is wrong
without seeing text
because because of what the
the environment it produces
it produces an environment that is that
is
that is uh in opposition
to what is pleasing to allah
give an example
i'll give an example
as i was exiting out of the music
industry
you know a lot took me through took me
through steps
like i said it wasn't something where i
just totally exited out
i was able to notice certain things
by the mercy of allah he took me through
steps allah took me through steps
and allowed me to see certain things
first so that i can develop that
that that that absolute certainty
that this was not something that was
good for me
it was not good for me at all and once i
turned away from it
i'm never coming back to it you
understand
so
i'll give you i'll give you i'll give
you a prime example
my former manager
and if she if she happens to watch this
she will she will remember when she said
this to me
before i totally exited out of the music
industry
i was trying to do performances i was
trying to do things in the what what
people would consider a very
conservative way
clean
trying to clean up my environment okay i
want to i don't want to have any alcohol
at my performances i don't want to have
this at my performances i want to try to
clean things up
and one thing she said something to me
that struck me eddie and i will never
forget this
she said but you know when people hear
your songs listen to this
she said when people hear you playing
and singing they listen to you
they listen to you play guitar they may
want to sip you know a little bit of
wine
she said they may want to sip a little
bit of wine or drink something
i said whoa
that was a sign that was that was one of
the signs for me right there
that was one of the signs right there
for me
like okay you're saying that them just
hearing me sing
what i'm saying
and play my guitar
is making them want to pick up some
alcohol and drink
because some things you don't realize
the effects it has on
sometimes you may do something you don't
realize the effect it has on other
people
mm-hmm
but she informed me
about something i didn't know
and in that case she was it was me
asking the people of knowledge
because she was the receiver in this
area yeah
they've done they've done
that they've done hundreds of studies i
mean the scientific studies you know the
special frequencies in music how they
affect the brain waves you have one
particular study 2012 by a psychologist
annette shermer
talking about the direct
effect these musical rhythms
having our perception right
our perceptions and so the this is
there's science behind you know how
music effect
how you music these instruments and the
rhythms and the frequent certain
frequencies
you know
the certain frequencies how they affect
they i saw one
one video
that was showing a
person in the studio who's like a sound
engineer
and then he was comparing the
frequency to the standard music that
people listen to beyonce jay-z and all
this stuff and what it was doing you
know to the kind of the kind of rhythms
it was producing wow but then he played
the at that
then
and it was totally it was something like
it was a peaceful rhythm it was
something
just kind of more tranquil now imagine
we need we need to sponsor a study like
that eddie
yes yes we need to sponsor a study where
what people are
when they when they put the headphones
on a person listening to music because
we need some we need to do our own
science behind this inshallah do some
studies serious about this
where people are listening to music
and then
a person is play some quran
or the other
and see the effects it has on the human
body because you can do these studies
now
and i'm interested to see
what they're able to to uh
to come up with what they're able to see
scientifically
yeah this is form of the effects that it
has on the soul
we've been informed about that
so we want to i want i'm interested to
see what what what science will be able
to reveal
in regards to that it'll be very there
you go this could be a catalyst to kick
it off we get some scientists muslim
scientists out there contact you contact
us and let's make this happen a good
funded study on this this would be very
very very important crucial so you have
all these different studies you know
proven this the effects that it has on
the human body mind you know altering
your perceptions one comparison is like
you know male malware you know malware
and then the viruses in the malware and
then it goes into human body so these
rhythms you know the music and the you
know the saxophone and the music all the
instruments that you enjoyed playing
playing for eight hours that's like the
malware and then most people don't
listen to the lyrics
that are behind me song that's the
poison that's coming in right
talk about that talk about that i don't
know you understand that that's deep
they get you with i heard anyone break
it down like that
i'm deadline but that's a very good
example that's a very good example man
because
like you said you will find
people in the club right for example
dancing to something
and inside of the poison inside of the
song itself
is
is the fame in women
mm-hmm
and she's singing it
can you imagine she's repeating it
that is that is that is speaking badly
about her
it's defaming her
you know and it's it's very
that should tell us something right
there
um and she's repeating it
like we said
it could be repeated it could be recited
it's listened to
and it has the total opposite effect
because that woman as a result of that i
mean let's just be honest
music is responsible for a lot of babies
outside of wedlock
let's let's keep it honest let's keep it
real yes
it's responsible for a lot of xena
raw keep it wrong
or adultery
where you may find
two
people from the opposite sex just in an
elevator together for example
and they hear a song
and that could do something to their
heart
why the while they are in seclusion
that can affect the heart
so that's why though even those places
you know it can be dangerous especially
when when music is being played but
you know that's that's a that's a that's
a you know
what people would consider an extreme
example but it's real
inshallah this can be of motivation to
get people to really go a little bit you
know deeper and to i've had guests on
who have talked about you know the
alistar crowsleys and the you know the
influencers people who actually and we
talked about this last time uh let's
move on to that like direct in this last
video that we had you look that you were
the brothers took and they made you
narrate over you were narrating over um
some of the effects really nicely done
and you were talking about the gin
actually you know invoking like what did
you mean by that like now we at another
level right now you're opening up the
door to this unseen world they go even
deeper when you go you know with these
uh
the unknown spiritual dimension with the
world of the jinn
and
wow i mean this is this is a whole
like i said it's a whole different
element when you when you talk about
adding
the
the effects it can have on you you know
that the gin could have on you now
because for people that don't understand
what the gin is
um this is another creation
that the creator of the heavens and
earth created before us
and unlike what people
uh believe
despite what people believe regarding uh
satan for example being a fallen angel
jim's being fallen angels because i've
had discussions with people in regards
to that
you know they are a different creation
people need to understand that they are
they are a different completely
different creation
from angels
and human beings
and they existed long before us they are
created from a smokeless fire
we believe that
iblis or satan he
he is a he's from amongst the gym he's
he's a gym
so when you understand this that there's
a separate creation
and i was just speaking very interesting
i was speaking to someone regarding this
last night
um
as i mentioned to you earlier
when you understand that there's a
different creation
watching you
and some of them like i said you know
it's not something that people should be
afraid of but it's rather you should be
conscious of it
that there is another creation that
lives
you know lives around us
uh
and many of them are not paying us any
attention they're not you know they have
their own business
you know they have they have their
families they get married they have
children just like you and i
but then there are some
that are
that are interacting with human beings
and you can literally
um eddie you can literally type in you
can find
stories where women
are complaining about something
attacking them at night
that they can't see you can type this
i've seen stories of this
i mean more than i would say 10 years
ago
when women are complaining about
something attacking them at night that
they don't see
you know and and um and actually having
intercourse with them and they can't see
it
something they can't see
and they're looking for help they're
crying out
and this seems to be prevalent in the
west by the way
where there is uh you know i would say a
lack of
connection to the to the creator of the
heavens and earth
as a result
of
what we're discussing now music being
played in the home
person may you know have a number of
things but let's talk about that element
of music
being played in the home and how that
opens you up
okay let's let's let's give a prime
example
um
you know
if you're in the house and they pray
they playing
thong song for example
or some artists or they're playing
something that is displeasing
to the creator of the heavens and earth
to almighty god
they're playing a song as displeasing to
him and all of music is in that category
as far as far as i'm concerned you know
as we mentioned
but let's let's give an example an
extreme example
is that creation that creation is trying
to harm you and many of them are
followers of satan many of the jinn are
followers of satan you have muslim jinn
you have christians you have hindu jin
they have our religions the same
religions we follow many of them many of
them follow
you know
i would i would encourage people read
sort of legitimate
read the the chapter in the quran that
is referring to the gem you have some
that are good and some of that are not
so those ones that are not good and they
wish evil for you they wish they wish to
cause you harm
and if you are engaging in something
that's displeasing to the creator of the
heavens and the earth
this opens you up even more to them
because
contrary to that if you are making your
salah and you are making your of call
every day
you are in other words you're you're
you're you're saying thing you're saying
prayers to protect yourself from them
then they you know
they can they can they can't harm you
except you know with the permission of
allah in the first place they can't harm
you
but you open yourself up to these things
if you are engaging in the things that
are displeasing to allah this is the key
thing
you're engaging in something that that's
displeasing to allah
so you open yourself up in fact
you know we hear we we heard a story
before there was a brother that was
doing rookie
on a system
and
you know who i am how how true this
story is but coming from a musician
coming from a musician's background i
can totally relate to that
she was as he was reciting over her he
began the jinn began to speak to the
brother
and he asked him he asked the jinn why
did you present possess the system
and what did jin mention is that
she was listening to music at the time
she had headphones on her ears and she
was listening to music so as a result it
made it easy for me to possess
subhanallah
you left the door open not even
she opened herself up
and this is related to drugs
you know um alcohol
because music is people don't understand
music is like a drunk it's like an
alcohol it's like alcohol
it's like you're drinking alcohol with
your ears
that's a very interesting way to put it
it's like you're drinking alcohol with
your ears you're being poisoned
so if she's walking around listening to
something that's displeasing to allah
and that has an effect on the heart soul
etc
according to this gin if that story is
true as we mentioned
it made it easier for him to possess her
you could talk to a lot of rockies who
confirmed this hearing you know this
would be anecdotal but you can go ahead
and
you know it's a frequent case you've
heard this so many times
uh likewise when you get into situations
where you talk about alexa crawley and
the beatles and
the beaches
eddie it's not something that people
would consider a conspiracy theory it's
not a theory anymore they write about
this
these things
they've written books yeah yeah
they have their own interviews we don't
have to try to try to say oh this oh
this is conspiracy theory no no no no
they have their own statements i'll give
you example one of the guys from the
beaches
he said when his spirit there was a
spirit that used to come and speak to
him and when it started to speak to him
in the beginning he used to be fearful
of it
and then he became comfortable with it
and this is the spirit that used to help
him write songs
uh
yes they used to write up used to help
him write songs
michael you know so he he's not he
yeah he's not the only one many of these
artists have confessed that yeah they've
come out
spirits
and what we just described if a person
says spirits to a muslim they would
automatically understand this
for a muslim that has the basics
basics of you know you know the basics
and knowledge but understand this to be
the gym right away
because when we talk about spirits and
dr bilal phillips i feel like has
written
books on this subject it was actually
his book that he translated
uh by evan samia essay on legit this
assisted me in becoming a muslim
i read that book two times before i was
a muslim and it made absolute sense to
me
especially regarding the things i had
had experienced in my life previously
regarding the you know things that are
unseen my family spoke about these
things so much so understanding the
gender wasn't something strange to me it
wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't uh you know it wasn't strange
at all to me if a person came to tell me
you know came to speak to me about the
gym so when i saw it wasn't strange but
the point i'm making here is that
spirits when you hear about spirits
we know as muslims and not something
that
uh you know where people are or could be
referring to spirits of the dead
as we know in islam the dead don't
communicate with human beings when they
when they're simply walking around etc
certain things can happen in dreams
that's a whole different story
but when you're talking about being
awake
people saying that you know they their
dead cousin came to visit them etc these
are these are nothing but the gym
these things are nothing but the gym
because
you know the dead does they don't
communicate they're not able to
communicate in that way
so
when you open yourself up to these
things
you always open yourself up to the gym
oh man you're talking about something
different happen
eddie we can there's so many things that
could arise as a result of this i'm
talking about even things such as
certain mental conditions it can be a
res you know a person feeling like for
example that they feel more feminine all
of a sudden
if that person engaged is engaging and
listening to music
this could have been the doorway
to that person feeling like that because
because if he's a male
he could have a female jimmy with him
that likes likes him and as a result has
entered into him
and he feels what more feminine all of a
sudden
or a female that feels all of a sudden
more
you know masculine
all of a sudden
or they feel like they were they were
they were i mean let's get into it they
can get it to a whole different topic as
you can see
you know we could we can go to a whole
different topic but the point being is
when you engage in these things
your openness you're definitely opening
yourself up and it's clear
when you find that musicians themselves
engaged in it willingly for assistance
look at that
many of them engaged in it willingly
seeking assistance
as you've seen napoleon speak about this
before
with certain hip-hop groups etc they
engaged in this
seeking assistance from the gym
some artists would say that i was not
able to sing that night
for example my voice was gone
so my spirit
you know
my companion
or my my my alter ego
took over for me that night beyonce
there was a documentary that was uh
showing a lot of this stuff and and one
of those they had clips of beyonce
actually talking about exactly what
you're talking about sasha yeah
oh okay you've heard that sasha yes yeah
who's sasha
i mean
you find them speaking about raymond
number of artists speaking about raymond
who's raymond
why are they deifying raymond raymond
or what are they seeking from raymond
you know
um
and like i said it's no way there is no
way you can just
dismiss
all of these accounts
you know
this would be on the you know the
highest level of hadith science when you
hear something so much
and it becomes so people speak about it
so much
you know it has a change
of transmission that's so long
you know
this is this is definitely the case here
you can't dismiss these claims you just
simply can't dismiss it you cannot
brothers and sisters ladies and
gentlemen
we're bringing you an expert in this
area former def jam artist somebody
again who is playing multiple
instruments who knows the ins and outs
exposing the music industry and the
deeper part of it that many people just
don't think about they don't really
reflect you know just bobbing your head
you know to the beats
and next to you know you open yourself
up to all these traumas and dramas you
know you're wondering where is this
coming from why am i feeling a certain
way mental health issues you know people
are not uh connecting the dots you know
and this gin possession what you said
about this sister happening you know
many cases like this opening yourself up
why open yourself up why you've you've
had people come out and testify you know
to these things you know you have so
many stories so the question is why do
you think some some people i mean that's
one thing you're a muslim you know your
purpose in life you know right this the
details about it you have some people
who kind of run they for this experience
right doing the ouija boards and they're
calling up it's like
people who are running towards this
connection with
with the jinn
so you said why do you think people run
to that connection
i think it's
yeah what what drives people
you know
you would think a lot of times you have
the fitra that drives you to your
creator so if you're not taking this
and connecting it to the creator now you
got people trying to connect it to all
sorts of things even the gin
yes
i think one of the things that that
connects them
honestly eddie is music
i think music is back back back to back
to the right back to that
music is the number one thing
that drives them to one wanting to have
that connection imagine if you were to
here
let's look at the opposite imagine a
person that just grew up here in quran
they never heard music a day in their
life before and of course that's very
hard to find in this day and age
maybe you have to go to some remote
place perhaps in motitania for example
when they're out in the desert and you
may be able to find a person that's
never heard music a day in his life
you know it's possible
so that person is going to be striving
to get closer to who they're gonna get
they're gonna be striving to get closer
to allah
in a situation like that
because they're always hearing his
speech they always listen to listening
to the speech of allah being recited
likewise a person that grows up
in the household for example my
household
bob marley was being played
stevie wonder was being played michael
jackson was being played marvin gaye was
being played james brown
all of these people were being played in
the home so as a result
i became what
i started what at a young age
singing
dancing
playing instruments
because of what the environment that i
was brought up in
if my family was a doc was a family of
doctors eddie
chances are
you know i'm going to take on that
family role as well i'm going to take on
that same
that same profession
that same profession most likely i'm
going to become a doctor as well if the
whole family
you know i even saw one guy who stopped
to talk about how his family all of them
were police officers
so as a result
you know he became a police officer
even though his dream was to go to the
nfl
he did he he ended up getting injured
and ended up going to
going to become what police officer
so likewise if your environment
is soaked in it's deeply
you know
it's deeply uh soaked in you know with
you know music is soaked in the
environment and that's the reality
especially in the west
eddie and this is almost everywhere now
where music is solved into these
environments
even you look in any muslim country
where music has been
uh
placed
now people have the have the ability to
listen to music on their smartphone
their tablets their iphone you know
their ipads whatever it is they have the
ability now to listen to music in these
places
i guarantee you you see more facade in
these places now more
more more uh uh more evil that has taken
place now in those environments
guaranteed
as a result and i guarantee you can look
at the statistics and they will tell you
that
it's not something you you don't have to
listen to me 100 people don't have to
listen to me i would encourage you to
take my advice
however
just look at the statistics
even in muslim countries where music is
entered
the youth when they're coming up
they've become so distracted by
you know it has formed a different
character within these individuals
it has raised up different individuals
versus the past when people were
it's clear
i'm going to push back a little bit and
just go ahead and
give you some
questions that someone might you know
think be thinking because they might had
have had someone who's gone overseas who
studied he's now a american imam who's a
someone who's a scholar they take as and
he says look it's no problem because
we're identifying with the culture rock
kim or some of these other you know
common sense somebody some of these
other rappers out there there's nothing
wrong with it they're not singing like
you know you can't compare them to 50
cents or some of the other cisco you
know these are the kind of things i grew
up listening to this is a mom now and
he's saying like hey this is okay
how would you respond to that
very good question eddie and um
as i was mentioning to a young
to a young man even
yesterday i've had these discussions
with certain scholars
there was a scholar of syria for example
that i spoke to
and see people try to
eliminate
the effects of the music itself
they try to eliminate that from the
conversation they try to remove that
from the conversation
and they try to focus just on lyrical
content no no no it's not about that
let's go to jazz
we're not hearing
no
lyrics at all
when you're just hearing a band play for
example
many of the jazz musicians eddie were
known to engage with the gym
many of the jazz musicians
many of you know
the top
jazz musicians musicians
musicians of the past
they were
known to engage in certain practices
with the gym
outside of that
let's say they never engage with them at
all
music itself
eddie like i said
as allah mentions
ask the people of knowledge
if you don't know
if you don't know something
and in regards to this question many of
the people that are
you know are quote unquote scholars
in certain fields they're not scholars
in this field
people like myself and
dr bilal phillips for example sheikh
bilal
spoke about how he himself used to be a
musician we understand these things on a
different level it's hard to explain to
someone
but even when you're speaking to me
about music
like i mentioned to you i spoke to the
uh i had a discussion with the scholar
of syria
in the past um in the uk
and i'll give you a prime example
and i asked the sheriff because he he he
he was he asked me what is wrong with
music he said why did you stop playing
guitar
because my whole show that i did was
based on
um
my transformation how i
i got away from playing guitar etc he
said i don't understand what's the issue
with this and he wanted to
uh the arabic terms that were used in
the past he said no this is not really
related to music
it's not related to music etc he wanted
to the things
uh you know from from arabic language he
went into it he addressed it from an
arab language standpoint
so i flipped it on
i started speaking about the effects
of it and this is what i normally
do
rather than going into the nesus going
going into the text itself sometimes i
speak about it from from a an effects
standpoint i believe
allah
he used to speak about it from this
angle as well
so i asked the chef i said [ __ ]
how long did it take you to memorize
quran because by the way he brought up a
point he said my son
plays guitar
just like you
still to this day
and eddie what i'm going to say is going
to shock you so i said sheikh and he and
i had a long walk we were walking around
in in london
having a discussion
he was very confident about what he had
to say in the beginning
but i will explain later what ended up
happening so i asked the chef okay
how long did it take you to memorize the
quran
he said it took me about two or three
years keep in mind he's an autumn
so when you understand what is being
said it should
you should be able to memorize the quran
much much faster it's general generally
speaking allah knows best he said it
took him about two or three years to
memorize the
quran i said what about your son because
he mentioned by the way that his son
started memorizing quran and shortly
after he started learning how to play
play the play and play the guitar
he said i said so what about your son
how long did it take him him to memorize
the quran i already knew the answer
before he even said anything subhanallah
he said his son
has never finished
the quran
i said [ __ ] you mean to tell me after 16
years
from the time your son started
memorizing quran and he's an adam
he hasn't finished the quran
the chef as i said to you what i'm going
to say at the end is going to shock you
the [ __ ] he came in in the conversation
very confident
he left the conversation with me shaking
his head out of confusion
he was confused
because he realized
that his son
had not memorized quran
what i was trying to explain to him i
said chef the reason your son has never
finished
finished the quran is because he was
learning he was playing guitar at the
same time
and those two things can't mix in the
hearts
they cannot mix in the heart
and eddie from my experience
living in egypt for example egypt is a
place subhanallah where you find so many
there it's so many people that have
memorized the quran indonesia
so whenever i would get into a car with
a taxi driver if i found him listening
to music
i would kindly ask him brother can you
kindly turn off the music inshallah
without a couple of feet and he would do
so
and then i would engage in conversation
with him
i would ask him i would say brother you
know uh
i would ask him how you know when he
started listening to music etc
etc and i would ask him how much of the
quran he
how much of the quran he had memorized
eddie shockingly
in a place like egypt
where i said uh there are so many people
that have memorized the quran in egypt
quran is like drinking water memorizing
quran is like drinking water in egypt
you will go on the bus and you will see
an old man reciting on the bus like
you will see him reciting
sounding like [ __ ]
and he would just be sitting on the bus
reciting while the people are watching
in amazement
that is the culture of egypt it's
beautiful
and every single time that i've spoken
to someone that was listening to music
as a taxi driver and i asked him how
much quran has he memorized he would
tell me three or four swords
and he will be referring to the small
swords in the quran
eddie
don't we see
the clear example
isn't it isn't it clear to us yeah the
effects of music that's really deep
everything
this is a treat so this [ __ ] the shake
the sheik that you were talking to so he
was an advocate because his son was
learning how to play that was a guitar
he was an advocate and he
he was asking me why why did you stop
playing guitar there's nothing wrong
with that
and when he engaged in conversation with
me he when he and i conversed regarding
this issue
he was completely confused afterwards
after he actually saw the long-term
effects now
the light the light bulb went on now
like my his his son he's memorized
subhanallah yes
you know inshallah hopefully i opened up
something for him
hopefully open up for a lot of people
because
it doesn't it doesn't
go ahead i'm sorry
you said it happened so many times
it's happened so many times to me where
people engage with engage in this
conversation with me
and i and they leave leave leave
confused because the reality is that
you know the truth is is going to stand
clear from falsehood
it's going to allah is going to make the
truth stand clear from the falsehood
that's what's going to be clear
so
if you ask a person of knowledge
regarding this issue
you were clear he would clearly
understand like look
okay now the information you're brought
to me now my opinion is a bit different
now i see where you're coming from
perhaps some of the some of the
quote-unquote scholars
or people of knowledge maybe they have
not spoken to a person of knowledge in
this field
you know they have not spoken to a
person
of knowledge from this field which kind
of clouds their judgment me personally i
don't see how they can dismiss the clear
narrations the clear
text regarding this issue in islam i
don't see how they got away from that
first and if if you yeah go ahead
you don't you don't know how they got
away finish your thought
but being that they escaped that being
that they want to put that to the side
right
um
then you have to come speak to someone
such as myself
or others that have engaged
in this practice
you have to come and speak to us because
then we will clear up the misconceptions
any time you sit with a scholar in the
area someone that has mastered something
you sit with that person
if you have even if you even if right
now if i have an issue if there's an eye
i want to understand
that i'm having an issue understanding
the first thing i'm going to do i'm
going to go speak to a a specialist in
tafsir
i'm going to go find one of the one of
the scholars here in gaming that have
specialized in tafsir and i'm going to
get him
can you explain this to me explain this
ayat to me because i'm having a hard
time understanding or uh i want to get a
deeper insight into what this tire means
i'm going to go ask a specialist to tap
steer
likewise in an area
of such as music
you know
someone has to ask someone who
specializes in that area
so they can clear up these
misconceptions
and i i and i encourage all you know
every
any well-known speaker
whoever it may be come speak to me
i challenge them i always do
eddie come and challenge
challenge me in
you know regarding
the permissibility of music and perhaps
you'll go away shaking your head and
this is not the most it's just something
that allah has blessed me with
i feel confident
in discussing this matter with people i
feel very confident there is no i have
no doubt there is no doubt in my mind
that music is not permissible i have
zero doubt eddie
you know someone could be up against the
fence
i'm not again not up against the fence
in regards to musical instruments
forget about the lyrical content i said
you don't even have to add the lyrical
content in it for me
i understand the effects of it even
without lyrics being involved now even
if now
now let's get to the issue
of
what some scholars have said about music
generally speaking
let's go to the more liberal side right
even if you go to the more liberal side
and this gives you an indication i think
that people just
unfortunately may allah we ask allah to
assist us all as i said earlier we are
all under construction
we are all under construction until we
go to the grave
we are all under construction
and we are striving to be better
individuals every day
but
with that being said
we
we see something
such as music
and
it's
you
you can't
you can't it's
the reality here you can't as we said we
can't dismiss many of the arguments many
of the things that take place yeah
this game lost my thought for a second
but i'm thinking that
you were you're going on before we
conclude uh we got a few minutes left
you were mentioning the liberal scholars
ah yes
the liberal scholars in this regard
let's take the most liberal opinion
that there's nothing wrong with music
musical instruments and you can listen
to anyone you want to listen to
without
you know as long as the lyrics are good
that's the most liberal liberal opinion
that i've heard
it gives you this gives you an ex gives
you the example
it shows you
how people are people unfortunately they
want to follow their desires the reason
i say that
you have not heard a single scholar
not even the most liberal
people
that say you can listen to jay-z
or beyonce
or rihanna
or any of these artists you have you
have not heard a single scholar so you
can listen to them that's across the
board now we can end that debate there's
nothing no one just get that out of your
mind i've not heard of the the most
liberal i've never heard of them saying
you can listen to them because all of
them are talking about xena
and alcohol drugs whatever it may be
you know
so i've never heard of a person say you
can listen to them so it shows you how
unfortunately we as human beings
we tend to follow our desires
when we want to follow what allah
reveals
and not do without us to crawl they
mention
which many people are preaching
do as do as do what you want to do in
other words and and modern standard
english doers die well yeah as a human
being
and we find many brands out there
actually promoting that
is the complete opposite
allah says that he has not created
the jinn
nor mankind except that they
that allah has created
death and life
to see which which one of us
our best in doing good deeds
our best a lot of them say the ones that
are that i can do that can do the most
deeds
allah said the ones that are doing the
best deeds
so that means it must be done with assad
and there's conditions a person must be
seeking the absolute pleasure of allah
islam
and it must be done according to the
sunnah the prophet sallallahu alaihi
so where does seeking your own desires
come into play
when you're talking about this this game
of the dunya
trying to seek this life
trying to seek the pleasure of the
almighty creator
so you can enter into the agenda the
paradise
this this life is nothing but a
deceiving enjoyment
so we're here only
only to seek the pleasure of almighty
god as allah clearly defined for us what
is the purpose of life
i have not created
jinn no mankind except that they should
worship me
so that's what we are here on this
planet
that's what al hamdulillah robotics hey
this is what you you've been calling
people to for many years on the d show
to come to the worship
of the creator of the heavens and the
earth and distance yourself
from the worship of the creation
distancing yourself
stand away from worshiping the creation
and that includes yourself your own
desires
as allah mentions have you not seen the
one the english translation allah says
have you not seen the one that made his
desires
a lord besides besides me
he has made his desires a lord
his rope he's made his desires
his his object of worship
his elab
you understand so
this should this this should show us a
lot about the plots of music the plots
etc because when you look at the concept
of idol
american idol
what are they doing eddies
they're making these people what what
wasn't what is an idol
an idol is an object of worship of
worship yes something you direct your
worship to
so what were people doing with michael
jackson they were worshiping michael
jackson
mm-hmm
so what do you mean moderate moderate
what is your idol modern day worship yes
people
let's let's let's be honest when people
used to meet michael jackson or when
he's performing people will be fainting
in an audience
people will be fainting crying profusely
when they meet michael jackson
you understand when the beatles were
performing
people would be going crazy
they were worshiping them
that the person who dies
and he has made partners with allah
allah has made the paradise forbidden
for that person
and allah
that person's
place is in the hellfire
that's serious
yeah
but a lot will forgive anything other
than that
there is this oh there is always
you know
there's always allah allah always leaves
hope for the people
because allah says that he forgives
anything other than that well y'all feel
my do
in another verse
allah says that he forgives anything
other than shirk
other than making partners with him he
forgives anything other than that
so if a person dies as long as they're
not committing [ __ ] with allah they have
a chance
and this should give a person delight
they have a chance even though we want
to we want to strive to be the best
but if a person dies drinking alcohol a
person dies committed to see that person
even dies listening to music
inshallah they still have the
opportunity to enter into gender
you know they allah can punish them if
he wills or allah can choose to choose
to let them be without punishing them
but if a person dies commits you should
with allah
allah has forbidden the paradise for
that person
in music to listen to music and i say
this to connect the dots
listening to music
can lead to the [ __ ] it can lead to
hypocrisy in the heart this is another
danger of music
because it can lead to hypocrisy
a person
having hypocrisy in the heart and him
leaving the fold of islam
and end up and that person can end up
committing [ __ ] or making partners with
allah
and i've seen this on multiple occasions
we have seen this
protect us from that
and inshallah this could be a benefit
mandatory watching
for the
father mother
who are facing this issue son comes to
his father daughter comes and wise music
haram
mandatory watching or for the people who
are indulging university whatever sit
down and watch this
and with an open heart and open mind
and inshallah this can be a great
benefit thank you so much now
let us uh like the last time we left you
left us with something be so beautiful
some quran
would you can
can we uh
before we end can you go ahead also uh
and recite some quran for us
yes yes it will be it will be my
pleasure inshallah
this time i will
i will open up the uh
the moosehoff on the phone inshallah i
can read from the museum
and um
subhanallah we can recite a beautiful
ayah
now we have ladies and gentlemen former
def jam
musician
went from playing with all the different
famous celebrities musicians to now
being someone who submitted his will to
the creator of heavens and earth is
living his true purpose
and he's going to recite some of the
verbatim word of god almighty you're
going to get to hear it maybe for the
first time now
this is the words
of the creator now compare how that will
make you feel compared to all the other
stuff that's making your heart race and
and god knows what else is doing to you
there's a wonderful verse
it's a wonderful sort
that um
when people hear this
um i
believe it really has a wonderful
effect effect on the hearts of the
people
because
allah dallas speaks about a time
where
mankind we weren't even thought of
people didn't you know
we didn't even know ourselves i lost
penalty speaks about this
i want to be laying in a shape on your
money
[Music]
[Music]
in
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
m
[Music]
thank you very much brother thank you
very much it was uh honor having you
again on the program tell us now you
also have started in gamia you're doing
some wonderful work in the last couple
of minutes that we have tell us about
you know someone who went from leading
the former life used to live to actually
dedicating your life to making a
difference in the world
you know
talk about his work
as people can see
one of our one of the missions i would
say
my
my top mission
was my top missions in this dunya
knowledge
is helping people to connect to the book
of allah subhanahu wa
and here alhamdulillah
we have a girls school
here in gambia
we have over 100 students
[Music]
these students are young girls
memorizing the book of allah
every day
sun up to sundown memorizing the book of
allah and um becoming
better individuals they're learning the
religion
becoming better individuals
in the society
and it's amazing it's amazing how even
some of the parents here
how they are so appreciative
appreciative you may find parents here
that are that have not memorized quran
themselves or they may not even be
uh i would say strong practicing muslims
but yet they are bringing their children
see they know
even
the most simple muslim the simplest of
muslims they know that
they know how important how important
the quran is
they know how important it is so they
wish for their children to memorize the
crime they wish for their children to
memorize quran and the effects you see
the it hasn't it has a major effect even
on the on the parents themselves when
they see their children memorizing the
quran
it's amazing
it's really amazing here and
alhamdulillah where um we're finishing
up one of our buildings
finishing up the the
construction
here in the area called
in gambia and
we're looking forward to moving into
that building hopefully in some time
sometime in may once all of the funds
have been raised inshallah
and
we plan to move the girls from the
current location
to a better location where it's more
spacious and it's more it's more of a
long-time long-term uh location because
the actual founders of the uh
organization actually own that land
there so
it's a huge it's a huge project man a
huge project
someone wanted to uh contribute or
support
is there means ways they can do that
yes we can um what we'll do is insha
allah share some information with you
that way you can be able to share with
others inshallah um but our website is
currently
going through it's under construction at
the moment but um we uh
shout out within the next few weeks
should be ready to even maybe uh receive
some donations on the website as well
all right brother thank you once again
for sharing one of your insights we've
got an expert on exposing
the
effects of
what's happening in this
industry that many people are following
and hopefully like god almighty allah
tells us go to the experts we brought
the expert in this area so hopefully any
imams or chefs or anybody has some
doubts of something you know
uh they're up for the challenge to watch
this and also
we can make the connection so we can
clear these doubts
because the truth is clear
alhamdulillah thank you so much may
allah bless you so much
foreign